five-minute crafts went medical let's
see if they're accurate
dry hair
[Music]
whipped cream eat it and then stick it
on your hair this is so ridiculous i
mean like look people have put fruit
juices and things like that in their
hair because a lot of the conditioners
just have like fatty acids in them to
replace the oil that is lost when you
over shampoo or you have dry skin it's
just it's too much it's unnecessary
okay this is an intimate setting here
[Music]
do you really need that like uh come on
i'm okay you really need that rest it on
your lap for god's sake
skiing take a selfie on the green screen
have some frostbite peeling skin
a banana
in case you're hungry
or just put the peel on your face not
egg on my face banana on my face because
i have frostbite means nothing doesn't
do anything
[Music]
oh that could be a sign of a fungal
infection or eczema or just dry skin
obviously but let's see what magical
treatment they have
oh
put a lemon in your sock ah imagine
that's the solution man like no you got
to figure out why you have the dry skin
you can't just put random fruits on your
feet and hope it solves all your
problems if she had psoriasis that lemon
would not have helped it would have
irritated the area with its acid and
made it 10 times worse
okay we got a painful foot
heel a heel sore heel blister
[Music]
did she just literally cut a piece of
her bra off what's easier let's do a
poll right here what's easier put a
band-aid
on your blister on your heel or stop
whatever it is you're doing remove your
bra cut a piece of it off so you could
never use your 50 bra again stuff it in
your shoe walk around with an unbalanced
bra what do you prefer
oh my back look at that red spot that
appeared
look at this bush what is she doing with
the bush oh my god if she eats the bush
salt
and bush it's salt bush
that will literally do
zero it won't harm you at all it will
absolutely waste your time and do zero
not now better now total misinformation
why
why
ring got stuck okay my prediction and my
hope is they'll do a little trick with
floss where you actually wrap floss
around your finger thereby making it
skinnier temporarily so you can pull it
off let's see what they do here oh no
they're going in the condom route
because it's five minute crafts
they're gonna
lubricate it
dude that was so unnecessary you could
have put lotion on it's the same thing
why did you waste a perfectly good
condom okay what's happening here
she's injecting a pad with water first
of all where did you get a syringe from
those aren't just sold over the counter
freeze use it as a cold compress
or
put some ice in a ziploc bag
crazy you even need the medical syringe
for that one whoa
uh stuffy nose allergies what's
happening here
okay the child doesn't want the medicine
wants the coca-cola is this a cola ad
what you're putting in
[Music]
oh that's messed up see if i was a kid i
would be pissed right now not only did
you lie to me so our trust is broken i'm
never gonna trust you again emotional
damage
i'm gonna associate the medicine with
being the worst experience in my life so
i never want to take it again what you
should do is do a little bargaining like
give the kids something positive before
and say look i gave you that let's do
the medicine or at least if you do the
medicine i'll give you that how do you
even know this child is taking the right
dosage what does her child not have
taste buds that she can't tell that it's
coca-cola activated charcoal
water
to see this is the thing about about oh
my god five minute crafts is so cheesy
they just try and make it look as visual
and crazy as possible the reality is
brushing your tongue good thing when you
brush your teeth also brush your tongue
at the end of the session like that is a
good idea i recommend it because food
gets trapped in there most of the bad
breath comes from the tongue but
activated charcoal is just going too far
like yes activated charcoal allows
binding of certain substances but it's
not going to solve your halitosis that's
coming from your heartburn it's not
going to solve the problems the halotosu
is coming from your gingivitis because
you don't floss regularly like me
okay teeth brushing with some heavy eye
makeup on top
a spoon
oh a fake spoon
just use your toothbrush for that
why did you need to cut open and break a
spoon that could potentially cut you
that looks so sharp that's an accident
waiting to happen don't do that one
either
headache grandma comes along
gives a nice little cuddle
has a first aid gift bag with sparkling
water
gives it to you
says not to drink it puts a magic robe
over your head
and spills it wait doesn't spill it lets
it sit on your head
and the headache goes aw
what can i say medically about that she
put a glass of water on her head on a
towel and said it would make her
headache go away in medicine we don't
even know what causes headaches yet but
putting a glass on the head imagine you
walk into a medical office and all you
see is people sitting with towels over
their heads with a glass of water being
held on by a nurse
this doctor looks funny i don't know why
i'm not buying that he's an actual
doctor
[Music]
he's confused that the child doesn't
want his heart listened to
hydro gel
i don't know what hydra gel is
and then you put the balloon
it becomes a stress ball
[Music]
who has those balls in their office you
might as well just have a small in the
office you know what i do which is so
much simpler is i inflate one of the the
gloves tie it off and it just looks like
a cow utter and let the kids play with
it then
peppers
oh cut okay
and she's going to cook an egg
she's going to take some of the egg
covering
and make it
this is so inaccurate it's painful just
put a band-aid on it and run it under
some warm water that's it
[Music]
oh that's a good stretch
that is a good stretch i'm with a little
cat cow action on the door you could use
resistance bands for stuff like this too
sugar coconut oil
made a homemade
mask for what is that stretch marks no
you cannot remove stretch marks that is
actual scarring of your skin when it
stretched too quickly it's scarred there
are some procedures surgically laser
that can take them off some creams maybe
do a little bit of hiding them but
removing them full on like that with any
natural product complete bs
okay what do we got a nose a pimple
okay so there's blackheads there
essentially black comedones are types of
acne almost where you have an opening so
therefore the oil or whatever is
plugging the gland actually oxidizes and
turns that darker color that's why you
could see it
this feels so largely unnecessary it's
incredible if you want to get rid of
your blackheads there are strips that
you can use for this there's uh special
cleansers you can use if you go to a
proper doctor's office you get a facial
they would do an extraction without
damaging your skin i've seen people
leave such bad imprints with their nails
in their noses and on their cheeks you
got to be really careful that when you
press leaving a deep impression like
that that can cause some real lasting
damage
dry lips that happens especially in the
winter time oh my god she's going with
the this is sponsored by colgate it has
to be i know some exfoliation on the
lips can be beneficial but the idea is
you want to hydrate them you want to
protect them you want to protect the
loss of fluids over licking your lips
can actually cause them to dry out
further because the water essentially
evaporates and dries out that
superficial layer and it begins to
slough off basically this video is just
like all of the subliminal footage and
messaging to encourage you to brush your
teeth
these individuals have some super
strange addictions let's talk about it
click here to check that i'll see you in
this video staying happy and healthy